welcome to the final episode of this
year's shocktober where we celebrate the
spookiest month of the year
by
spooking it up on the channel
today
assuming you're watching this on the day
that it comes out
is halloween which is for many the
culmination of the spooky month of
october
many people are out trick-or-treating
perhaps watching horror movies
making jack-o-lanterns and eating candy
for some people
today is sawin which is the ancient
pagan festival upon which at least
partly halloween is based and to some it
is just sunday but in any case i hope
you're all
enjoying yourselves and today we're
gonna do a bit of a special episode
because of the fact that it is halloween
not only will this be a spooky episode
just like most episodes that we do on in
the month of october it will also be
somewhat of a different format than what
i usually do here
in fact what i've chosen to do for
halloween this year
is that i have stolen an idea from my
friend justin on the channel esoterica
what he did last year on halloween was
that he actually read a ghost story
and that is exactly what we're going to
do today although not necessarily a
ghost story but i'm going to read you
a spooky story today and the story that
i have chosen to tell you is one of the
wonderful tales from the thousand and
one knights
also known more commonly perhaps as the
arabian knights as you hopefully know by
now the arabian nights is of course a
less than desirable name because a lot
of the stories from this vast collection
of tales
in fact originates in persia in north
africa and india
aside from arabic tales as well so it's
a
it is tales from a wide
range of cultures and so to simply call
it the arabian nights
is kind of
not the greatest thing therefore the
thousand and one nights is a much better
title and also actually corresponds to
the original arabic title much more
which is alpha layla
meaning literally a thousand and one
knights there's of course a lot of
stories from this collection there's the
famous ones like aladdin and his
wonderful lamp there is the story of
simbad the sailor alibaba and the 40
thieves the fishermen and the jinn
a lot of really great and magical
stories and some of them are actually
quite spooky there's one story about a
haunted house
which ends up not being very spooky at
all in the end but there's also another
story which is the one i have chosen to
read today and that story goes under the
name the city of brass
not one of the most famous stories from
the 1001 nights of course but it is
quite a spooky one that features well a
city of brass
a ghost town of sorts as well as caleb's
and of course as all of these stories do
they it contains gin so sit back in your
chair or sofa enjoy yourself make
yourself comfortable and let's celebrate
this
spooky
season by reading a spooky tale from the
thousand and one nights entitled the
city of brass
i will be reading a translation by
edward william lane from the early 20th
century it's quite an old translation
which features kind of old-timey english
i will be
adjusting the translation a bit when i
find it necessary to make it a bit more
understandable to a modern audience but
largely i will be following
this translation by
lane
when i read this story
so here is the city of brass from the
thousand and one nights
there was an olden time and in an
ancient age and period in damascus of
syria a king one of the khalifas named
abdul malik ibn marwan
and he was sitting one day having with
him the great men of his empire
consisting of kings and sultans when a
discussion took place among them about
the traditions of former nations
they called to mind the stories of our
lord solomon the son of david on whom
both be peace
and the dominion and authority which god
whose name be exalted had bestowed upon
him over mankind and the jinn and the
birds and the wild beasts and other
things
and they said we have heard from those
who were before us that god whose
perfection be exalted and whose name we
exalted bestowed not upon anyone like
that of which he bestowed upon our lord
solomon
and that he attained to that which none
other attained so that he used to
imprison the jinn and the matters and
the devils in bottles of brass
and pour molten lead over them and seal
this cover over them with a signet
then talib the son of sahil related that
a man embarked in a ship with a company
of others and they voyage to the island
of sicily and seized not in their course
until there arose against them a wind
which bore them away to one of the lands
of god whose name be exalted
this happened during the black darkness
of night and when the day shone forth
they came out to them from the caves in
that land people of black complexion
with naked bodies they had a king of
their own rays and none of them knew
arabic saved the king
so when they saw the ship and those who
were in her he came forth to them
attended by a party of his companions
and saluted them and welcomed them and
inquired of them respecting their
religion
they therefore acquainted him with their
state and he said to them no harm shall
befall you
and when he asked them respecting their
religion each of them was of one of the
religions prevailing before the
manifestation of islam and before the
mission of muhammad may god bless and
save him wherefore the people of the
ship said we know not what thou sayest
[Music]
then the king said to them there hath
not come to us any one of the sons of
adam before you
and he entertained them with a banquet
of the flesh of birds and wild beasts
and a fish beside which they had no food
and after this the people of the ship
went down to divert themselves in the
city and they found one of the fishermen
who had cast his net in the sea to catch
fish and he drew it up and lo it was a
bottle of brass which was sealed with
the signature of solomon the son of
david on both of whom be peace
and the fisherman came forth and broke
it whereupon there preceded from it a
blue smoke which united with the clouds
of heaven and they heard a horrible
voice saying repentance repentance o
prophet of god
then of that smoke there was framed a
person of terrible aspect
a terrific make whose head would reach
as high as a mountain and he disappeared
from before their eyes
as to the people of the ship their
hearts were almost eradicated but the
blacks thought nothing of the event and
the man returned to the king and asked
him respecting this and the king
answered him
know that this is one of the jinn whom
solomon the son of david when he had
incensed against them imprisoned in
these bottles and he poured lead over
them and threw them into the sea when
the fishermen casts his net it generally
brings these bottles and when they are
broken there comes forth from them ajin
who thinks that solomon is still living
wherefore he repents and says repentance
or prophet of god
and the prince of the faithful abdul
malik bin marwan
who is of course one of the most famous
caliphs in history one of the earliest
caliphs of the umayyad dynasty the
caliph who had the dome of the rock
built in jerusalem for example this is
abdul malik ibn marwan who is the who is
the important person in this story
the prince of the faithful abdul malik
ibn marwan wandered at these words and
said extol be the perfection of god
solomon was endowed with a mighty
dominion
and among those who were present at the
assembly was anabira and thebiani and he
said talib had spoken truth in that
which he had related and the proof of
his veracity is the saying of the wise
the first thus versified
and consider solomon when the deity said
to him perform the office of khalifa and
govern with diligence
and whoso obeyeth thee honor him for
doing so and who so disobeyeth thee
imprison him forever
he used to put them into bottles of
brass and to cast them into the sea
and the prince of the faithful approved
of these words and said by allah i
desire to see some of these bottles
so talib the son of sahil said o prince
of the faithful
you are able to do so and yet remain in
thy country
send to thy brother abdulaziz the son of
marwan desiring him to bring them to
thee from the western country that he
may write down orders to musa to journey
from the western country to this
mountain which we have mentioned and to
bring you what thou desirest of these
bottles for the furthest part of this
province is adjacent to this mountain
and the prince of the faithful approved
this vice and said o talib you have
spoken truth and that which you have
said and i desire that you be my
messenger to musa the son of musa for
this purpose and you shall have a white
and sign together with what you shall
desire of wealth and dignity or other
things and i will be your substitute to
take care of your family to this talib
replied most willingly o prince of the
faithful and the khalifa said to him
go independence on the blessing of god
and his aid then he gave orders that
they should write for him a letter to
his brother abdelaziz his viceroy in
egypt and another letter to musa his
viceroy in the western country
commanding him to journey himself in
search of the bottles of solomon
to leave his son to govern the country
in his stead and to take with him guides
to expand wealth and to collect a large
number of men and not to be remiss in
accomplishing that objective nor to use
any pretext to excuse himself he sealed
the two letters and delivered them to
talib the son of sahil commanding him to
hasten and to elevate the ensigns over
his head and he gave him riches and
riches of footmen to aid him in his way
he gave orders also to supply his house
with everything required
so taleb went forth on his way to egypt
he possessed with his companions
traversing the districts from syria
until they entered mr in other words
egypt when the governor of egypt met him
and lodged him with him and he treated
him with the utmost honor during the
period of his stay with him
then he sent with him a guide who
accompanied him to upper egypt until
they came to the emir musa the son of
and when he knew of his approach he went
forth to him and met him and rejoiced at
his arrival and talib handed to him the
letter
so he took it and read it and understood
its meaning and he put it upon his head
saying i hear and obey the command of
the prince of the faithful
he determined to summon the great men
and they presented themselves and he
inquired of them respecting that which
had been made known to him by the letter
whereupon they said o amir if you desire
him who will guide you to that place
have recourse to the sheikh of the
samadh the son of abdulhodus masmudi for
he is a knowing man and have traveled
much and he is acquainted with these
deserts and wastes and the seas and
their inhabitants and their wonders and
the countries and their districts
have recourse therefore to him and he
will direct you to the objects of your
desire
accordingly he gave orders to bring him
and he came before him and lo he was a
very old man whom the vicissitudes of
years and times had rendered decrepit
the emir musa saluted him and said to
him o sheikh abdul samad our lord the
prince of the faithful abdul malik ibn
marwan has commanded us thus and thus
and i possess little knowledge of that
land and has been told to me that you
are acquainted with that country and the
routes have you then a wish to
accomplish the affair of the prince of
the faithful the sheikh replied
know immediately that this route is
difficult far extending with few tracks
the immediate said to him how long a
period does it require he answered it is
a journey of two years and some months
going and the same for the return trip
and on the way are difficulties and
horrors and extraordinary and wonderful
things
moreover you are a warrior for the
defense of the faith and our country is
near unto the enemy so perhaps the
christians may come forth during our
absence it is expedient therefore that
you leave in your province want to
govern it he replied that he would and
left his son haroon as his substitute in
this province exactly an oath of
fidelity to him and commanded the troops
that they should not oppose him but obey
him in all that he should order them to
do
and they heard his words and obeyed him
then the amir musa said do you know if
any of the kings have gone to this land
before us
he answered him yes
this land belonged to the king of
alexandria darius the greek
after this they departed and they
continued their journey until they
arrived at a palace where upon the
sheikhs advance with us to this place
which presents a lesson to him who will
be admonished
so the emir musa advanced there together
with the sheikh abdul samad and his
chief companions till they came to its
entrance and they found it open and
having lofty angles and steps among
which two wide steps of colored marbles
the lack of which had not been seen
before the ceilings and walls were
decorated with gold and silver and
minerals and over the entrance was a
slab thereon was the inscription in
ancient greek and the sheikh of the
samadh said shall i read it oh emid the
emir answered advance and read
may god bless thee for nothing had
happened to us during this journey but
what had been the result of the blessing
attendant upon thee
so he read it and lo it was poetry and
it was this quote
here was a people whom after their works
thou shalt see wept over for their lost
dominion and in this palace is the last
information respecting lords collected
in the dust
death has destroyed them and disunited
them and in the dust they have lost what
they amassed
as though they had only put down their
loads to rest while quickly they have
departed
and the emir musa wept until he became
insensible and he said there is no deity
but god the living the enduring without
failure
he then entered the palace and was
confounded by its beauty and its
construction and he looked at the
figures and images that it contained
then they attentively viewed the palace
and lo it was devoid of inhabitants
destitutes of household and occupants
its courts were desolate and its
apartments were deserted and in the
midst of it was a chamber covered with a
lofty dome
rising high into the air around which
were four hundred tombs
to these tombs amir musa drew near and
behold among them was a tomb constructed
of marble then he drew near to the dome
crown chamber and low it had eight doors
of sandalwood with nails of gold
ornamented with stars of silver set with
various jewels and after he had
recovered he entered the chamber covered
with a dome and beheld in it a long tomb
of terrible appearance whereupon was a
tablet of iron of china
and the sheikh abdul samad junaire to it
and read its inscription and lo on it
was written quote in the name of god the
eternal the everlasting throughout all
ages in the name of god who beget not
and who is not begotten and unto whom
there is none like in the name of god
the mighty and powerful in the name of
the living who dieth not to proceed
o you who arrivest at this place
be admonished by the misfortunes and
calamities that you behold
and be not deceived by the world and its
beauty and by its falsity and calumny
and its fallacy and finery for it is a
flatterer a cheat a traitor
its things are borrowed and it will take
the loan from the borrower and it is
like the confused visions of the sleeper
and the dream of the dreamer as though
it were a sarab on the plane which
thirsty imagines to be water
the devil adorns it for man until death
these are the characteristics of the
world confide not therefore in it nor
incline to it for it will betray him who
depends on it and who in his affairs
relies upon it
fall not in its snares nor cling to its
skirts for i possessed four thousand bay
horses in a stable and i married a
thousand damsels of the daughters of
kings high bosomed virgins like moons
and i was blessed with a thousand
children like stern lions and i lived a
thousand years happy in my mind and
heart and i amassed riches such as the
kings of the regions of the world were
unable to procure and i imagined that my
enjoyments would continue without
failure
but i was not aware when the allied
among us in the terminator are delights
and the separator of companions the
desolator of abode and the ravager of
inhabited mansions the destroyer of the
great and the small and the infants and
the children and the mothers
we had resided in this palace in
security until the event decreed by the
lord of all creatures the lord of the
heavens and the lord of the earth befell
us and the thunder of the manifest truth
assailed us
and there died us every day too
till a great company of us had perished
so when i saw that destruction had
entered our dwellings and had alighted
among us and drowned us in the sea of
deaths i summoned a writer and ordered
him to write these verses and
admonitions and lessons and caused them
to be engraved upon these doors and
tablets and tombs
i had an army comprising a thousand
thousand bridles composed of hearty men
with spears and coats of mail and sharp
swords and strong arms and i ordered
them to clothe themselves with the long
coats of mail and to hang on the keen
swords and to place in rest to terrible
lances and mount the high blonde horses
then when the event appointed by the
lord of all creatures the lord of the
earth and the heavens befell us i said
oh companies of troops and soldiers can
you prevent what has befallen me from
the mighty king
but the soldiers and troops were unable
to do so and they said how should we
contend against him from whom none has
secluded the lord of the door that has
no doorkeeper
so i said bring to me the wealth and
they did so and when they had brought
the wealth before me i said to them can
you deliver me by means of all these
riches and purchase for me there with
one day during which i may remain alive
but they could not do so
they resigned themselves to faith and
destiny and i submitted to god with
patient endurance of faith and
affliction until he took my soul and
made me dwell in my grave
and if you ask concerning my name i am
cush the son of shaddad the son of ad
the greater
and again the emir musa wept until they
became insensible in considering the
fates of the people after which as they
were going about through the different
apartments of the palace and viewing
attentively its chambers and its places
of diversion they came to a table upon
four legs of alabaster and the emir musa
wrote all this then he went forth and
took not with him from the palace ought
to save the table
these soldiers proceeded with the shaykh
of the samad before them showing them
the way until all the first day had
passed and the second and the third
they then came to a hill
at which they looked and lo upon it was
a horseman of brass
on the top of whose spear was a wide and
glistening head that almost deprived the
beholder of sight and on it was
inscribed o thou who cometh to me if
thou know not the way that leadeth to
the city of brass rub the hand of the
horseman and he will turn and then we'll
stop and in whatsoever direction he
stops
there proceed without fear and without
difficulty for it will lead you to the
city of brass
and when the amir musa had rubbed the
hand of the horsemen it turned like a
blinding lightning and faced a different
direction from that in which they were
traveling the party therefore turned
there and journeyed on and it was the
right way
they took that route and continued their
course the same day and the next day
until they had traversed a wide tract of
country
as they were proceeding one day they
came to a pillar of black stone
wherein was a person sunk to his armpits
and he had two huge rings and four arms
two of them like those of the sons of
adam and two like the four legs of lions
with claws he had hair upon his head
like the tails of horses and two eyes
like two burning coals and he had a
third eye in his forehead like the eye
of the lynx
from which there appeared sparks of fire
he was black and tall and he was crying
out extol be the perfection of my lord
who has appointed me this severe
affliction and painful torture until the
day of resurrection
when the party beheld him their reason
fled from them and they were stupefied
at the sight of his form and retreated
in flight and the amir musa said to the
sheikh the samad what is this he
answered i know not what he is
and the amir said draw near to him and
investigate his case perhaps he will
discover it and perhaps you will learn
his history
the sheikh the samad replied may god
amend the state of the emir verily we
fear him fear ye not rejoin the emir for
he is withheld from injuring you and
others by the state in which he is
so the sheikh of the samara drew near to
him and said to him
o thou person what is thy name and what
is thy nature
and what has placed you here in this
manner
and he answered him
as to me i am an ifrit of the jinn and
my name is tasheesh the son of al-amish
and i am restrained here by the majesty
confined by the power of god tormented
as long as god to whom he ascribed might
and glory wills
the party therefore wandered at him and
the horrible nature of his form and the
emir musa said there is no deity but god
solomon was endowed with a mighty
dominion and the sheikh abdul samad said
to the ifrit o you i ask thee concerning
a thing of which you do inform us
the effort replied ask concerning that
which you will and the sheikh said are
there in this place any of the ifrits
confined in bottles of brass from the
time of solomon on whom bps the ifrit
answered yes in the sea of al-qarkar who
are a people of the descendants of noah
on hombi peace whose country and deluge
reached not and they are separated there
from the rest of the sons of adam and
where the sheikh is the way to the city
of brass and the place wherein are the
bottles
what distance is there between us and it
the ifrit answered it is near
so the party left him and proceeded and
there appeared to them a great black
object with two seeming fires
corresponding with each other in
position in the distance in the black
object whereupon the emir musa said to
the sheikh what is this great black
object and what are these two
corresponding fires
the guide answered him be rejoiced omid
for this is the city of brass
and this is the appearance of it that i
find described in the book of hidden
treasures that its wall is of black
stones and it has two towers of brass of
al andalus which the beholder sees
resembling two corresponding fires and
thence it is named the city of brass
they ceased not to proceed until they
arrived at it and lo it was lofty
strongly fortified rising high into the
air impenetrable the height of its wall
was 80 cubits and it had 5 and 20 gates
none of which would open but by means of
some artifice and there was not one gate
to it and had not within the city one
like it such was the beauty of the
construction architecture of the city
they stopped before it and endeavoured
to discover one of its gates but they
could not and the emir musa said to the
sheikh abdul samad o sheikh i see not to
this city any gate
the sheikh replied omid thus do i find
it described in the book of hidden
treasures that it has 5 and 20 gates and
that none of its gates may be opened but
from within the city
and how said the amid can we contrive to
enter it and divert ourselves with a
view of its wonders
then the minimooser ordered one of his
young men to mount a camel and ride
around the city in the hopes that he
might discover a trace of a gate or a
place lower than that to which they were
opposite
so one of his young men mounted and
proceeded around it for two days with
her nights prosecuting his journey with
diligence and not resting and when the
third day arrived he came in sight of
his companions and he was astounded at
that which he beheld of the extent of
the city and its height then he said oh
amir the easiest place in it is this
place at which you have alighted
and thereupon the emir musa took talib
the son of sahil and the sheikh the
samad and the ascended a mountain
opposite the city and overlooking it and
when they had ascended that mountain
they saw a city that which eyes had not
be held any greater
its pavilions were lofty and its domes
were shining its mansions were in good
condition and its rivers were running
its trees were fruitful and its gardens
bore ripe produce it was a city with
impenetrable gates empty still without a
voice or a cheering inhabitant but the
owl hooting in its quarters and birds
skimming in circles in its areas and the
raven croaking in its districts and its
great thought their streets and
bewailing those who had been in it
the emir moves are paused sorry for its
being devoid of inhabitants and it's
being despoiled of people and dwellers
and he said extol be the perfection of
him whose ages and times change not the
creator of the creation by his power
and while he was extolling the
perfection of god to whom he ascribed
might and glory he happened to look
aside and lo there were seven tablets of
white marble appearing from a distance
so he approached them and behold they
were sculptured and inscribed and he
ordered that their writing should be
read and therefore the sheikh abdul
samad advanced and examined them and
read them and they contained admonition
and matter for example and restraint
onto those endowed with faculties of
discernment upon the first tablet was
inscribed in the ancient greek language
quotes o son of adam how heedless art
thou the case of him who hath been
before thee
thy years and age have diverted thee
from considering him
knowest thou not that the cup of death
will be filled for thee and that in
short time thou will drink it look then
to thyself before entering thy grave
where are those who possess the
countries and abase the servants of god
and that armies
death has come upon them and god is the
terminator of delights and the separator
of companions and the devastator of
flourishing dwellings so he has
transported them from the amplitude of
palaces to the straightness of the
graves
and in the lower part of the tablet
we're inscribed these verses quote where
are the kings and the peoples of the
earth they have quitted that which they
have built and peopled and in the grave
they are pledged for their past actions
here after destruction they have become
putrid corpses where are the troops they
repelled not nor profited and where is
that city they collected and hoarded
the decree of the lord of the throne
surprised them neither riches nor refuge
saved them from it
and the emir musa fainted his tears ran
down upon his cheeks and he said by god
indifference to the world is the most
appropriate and the most sure course
then he caused an ink horn and paper to
be brought and he wrote the inscription
of the first tablet after which he drew
near to the second tablet and the third
and the fourth and having copied what
was inscribed on them he descended from
the mountain and the world had been
pictured before his eyes and when he
came back to the troops they passed the
day devising means of entering the city
and the emir musa said to his wazir
talib the son of sahil and to those of
his chief officers who were around him
how shall we contrive to enter the city
that we may see its wonders perhaps we
shall find in it something by which we
may ingratiate ourselves with the prince
of the faithful
talib the son of sahel replied may god
continue the prosperity of emir let us
make a ladder and mount upon it and
perhaps we shall gain access to the gate
from within
and the immediate said this is what
occurred to my mind an excellent is the
advice
then he called to the carpenters and
blacksmiths and ordered them to make
straight some pieces of wood and to
construct a ladder covered with plates
of iron and they did so and made it
strong
they employed themselves in constructing
it a whole month and many men were
occupied in making it and they set it up
and fixed it against the wall and it
proved to be equal to the wall in height
as though it had been made for it before
that day so the emir musa wondered at it
and said god bless you
it seems from the excellence of your
work as you have adapted it by
measurement to the wall he then said to
the people which of you will ascend this
ladder and mount upon the wall and walk
along it and contrive means of
descending into the city that he may see
how the case is and then inform us of
the mode of opening the gate
and one of them answered i will ascend
it or emit and descend and open the gate
the immediate therefore replied mount
god bless thee
accordingly the man ascended the ladder
until he had reached the top of it when
he stood then fixed his eye towards the
city clapped his hands and cried out
with a loudest voice saying thou art
beautiful
then he cast himself down into the city
and his flesh became mashed with his
bones
so the immediate moses said this is the
action of the rational how then will the
insane act if we do the same with all
our companions there will not remain any
one of them and we shall be unable to
accomplish our task and the affair of
the prince of the faithful
let's depart we have no concern with
this city
but one of them said perhaps another
then this may be more steady than he
and so a second person ascended
and a third and a fourth and a fifth and
they ceased not to ascend by that ladder
to the top of the wall one after another
until 12 men of them had gone acting
just as the first hand
therefore the sheikh abdul samad said
there is none for this affair but myself
and the experience did not like the
inexperienced but the emir moosa said to
him you shall not do that nor will i
allow thee to ascend to the top of this
wall for if you should die you will be
the cause of our deaths as well and
there would not remain of one of us
alive since you are the guide to this
party
the sheikh however replied perhaps the
object will be accomplished by my means
through the will of god whose name be
exalted and thereupon all the people
agreed to his ascending
then the shaykh of the samad arose and
encouraged himself
and having said the bismillah rahim he
ascended the ladder repeating the
praises of god whose name he exalted and
reciting the verses of safety until he
reached the top of the wall
then he clapped his hands and fixed his
eyes
the people therefore all called out to
him and said oh sheikh abdul samad do it
not and cast not thyself down
and they said verily to god we belong
and verily unto him we return
if the shaykh of the samad fall we all
perish
then the shaykh of the samad laughed
moderately and sat a long time repeating
the praises of god whose name be exalted
and reciting the verses of safety after
which he rose with energy and called out
with his loudest voice o emir no harm
shall befall you for god to whom
describe might and glory has averted
from me the effect of the artifice and
fraudulence of the devil through the
blessing resulting from the utterance of
the words bismillah
so the emir said to him what have you
seen
he answered when i reached the top of
the wall i beheld ten damsels like moons
who made a sign with their hands as
though they would say come to us
and it seemed to me that beneath me was
a sea or a great river of water
whereupon i desired to cast myself down
as our companions did
but i beheld them dead so i withheld
myself from them and recited some words
from the book of god
whereupon god averted from me the
influence of those damsels artifice and
they departed from me therefore i cast
not myself down and god repelled for me
the effect of their artifice and
enchantment
there is no doubt that this is an
enchantment and an artifice which the
people of this city contrived in order
to repel from it everyone who should
desire to look down upon it and wish to
obtain access to it and these are
companions are laid dead he then walked
along the wall till they came to the two
towers of brass when he saw that they
had two gates of gold without locks upon
them or any signs of the means of
opening them
therefore the sheikh paused as long as
god willed and looking attentively he
saw in the middle of one of the gates a
figure of a horseman of brass having one
hand extended as though he were pointing
with it and on it was an inscription
which the sheikh read and lo it
contained these words quote
turn the pin that is in the middle of
the front of the horseman's body 12
times
and then the gate will open
so we examined the horsemen and in the
middle of the front of his body was a
pin
strong firm well fixed and he turned it
twelve times where upon the gate opened
immediately and with a noise like
thunder and the shaykh of the samad
entered
he was a learned man acquainted with all
languages and characters
and he walked on until he entered a long
passage once he descended some steps and
he found a place with handsome wooden
benches on which were people dead and
over their heads were elegant shields
and keen swords and strong bows and
notched arrows
and behind the next gate were a bar of
iron and barricades of wood and locks of
delicate fabric and strong apparatus
upon this the said within himself
perhaps the keys are with these people
then he looked and lo there was a shaykh
who appeared to be the oldest of them
and he was upon a high wooden bench
among the dead men
so the sheikh abdul samad said may not
the keys of the city be with this sheikh
perhaps he was the gatekeeper of the
city and these were under his authority
he therefore drew near to him and lifted
up his garments and though the keys were
hung to his waist
at the side of them the sheikh abdul
saman rejoiced exceedingly his reason
almost fled from him in consequence of
his joy and he took the keys approached
the gate opened the locks and pulled the
gate and the barricades and other
apparatus which opened and the gate also
opened with a noise like thunder by
reason of its greatness and terribleness
and the enormousness of his apparatus
upon this the sheikh exclaimed god is
most great and the people made the same
exclamation with him rejoicing at the
event the emir musa also rejoiced at the
safety of the sheikh the samad and at
the opening of the gate of the city the
people thanked the sheikh for that which
he had done and all the troops hastened
to enter the gate
but the emir musa cried out to them o
people if all of us enter we shall not
be secure from some accident that might
happen
half shall enter and half shall remain
behind
emir musa then entered the gates and
with him half of the people who bore
their weapons of war
and the parties saw their companions
lying dead so they buried them
they saw also the gatekeepers and
servants and chamberlains and
lieutenants lying upon beds of silk all
of them dead
and they entered the market of the city
and beheld the great market with lofty
buildings none of which projected beyond
another the shops were opened and these
scales hung up and the utensils of brass
ranged in order and the cons were full
of all kinds of goods
and they saw their merchants dead in
their shops their skins were dried and
their bones were carious and they had
become examples of him who would be
admonished they saw likewise four
markets of particular shops filled with
wealth
and they left this place and passed on
to the silk market in which were silks
and brocades interwoven with red gold
and white silver upon various colors and
the owners were dead lying upon skins
and appearing almost as though they
would speak
leaving these they went on to the market
of jewels and pearls and jacinds
and they left it and passed onto the
market of the money changers whom they
found dead with varieties of silks
beneath them and their shops were filled
with gold and silver
these they left and they proceeded to
the market of the perfumers and though
their shops were filled with varieties
of perfumes and bags of musk and aloes
wood and ned and camphor and other
things
and the owners were all dead not having
with them any food
and when they went forth from the market
of the perfumers they found near unto it
a palace decorated and strongly
constructed and they entered it and
found banners unfurled and drawn swords
and strong bows and shields hung up by
chains of gold and silver and helmets
gilded with red gold and in the passages
of that palace were benches of ivory
ornamented with plates of brilliant gold
and with silk on which were men whose
skins had dried upon their bones
the ignorant would imagine them to be
sleeping but from the want of food they
had died and tasted mortality
upon this emir moves are paused
extolling the perfection of god whose
name be exalted and his holiness and
contemplating the beauty of that place
and its strong construction and its
wonderful fabrication in the most
beautiful form and with the firmest
architecture and most of its decorations
were an ultramarine
around them were inscribed these verses
quote
consider what thou beholdest man and be
on thy guard before thou departest
and prepare good provision and you may
enjoy it for every dweller in the house
shall depart
consider a people who have decorated
their abodes and in the dust have become
pledged for their actions
they built but their buildings availed
not and treasured but their wealth did
not save them when their term had
expired how often they hoped for what
was not decreed them but they passed to
the graves and hope did not profit them
and from their high and glorious state
they were removed to the narrowness of
the sepulcher evil is their abode
then there came to them a crier after
they were buried saying where are the
thrones and the crowns and the apparel
where are the faces which were veiled in
curtains and on which for their beauty
proverbs were composed
and the grave plainly answered the
inquirer for them and to the cheeks the
rose is gone from them
long time they ate and drank but now
after pleasant eating they themselves
have been eaten
and the emir musa wept until he became
senseless and afterwards having given
orders to write these verses he went on
into the interior of the palace
there he beheld the great hall and four
large and lofty chambers each one
fronting another wide decorated with
gold and silver and with various colors
in the midst of the hall was a great
founder of alabaster over which was a
canopy of brocade and in those chambers
were places one in each chamber
containing decorated fountains and tanks
lined with marbles and channels of water
flowed along the floors of those
chambers the four streams meeting
together in a great tank lined with
marbles of various colors
the imei musa then said to the shaykh
the samadh enter these chambers with us
so they entered the first chamber and
they found it filled with gold and with
white silver and pearls and jewels and
just synths and precious minerals
they found in it also chests full of red
and yellow and white brocades and they
went dense to the second chamber and
opened a closet in it and lo it was
filled with arms and weapons of war
consisting of gilded helmets and
davidian coats of male and indian swords
and lances of hather and maces of
charism and other instruments of war and
battle
then they passed to the third chamber in
which they found closets having upon
their doors closed locks and over them
were curtains worked with various kinds
of embroidery
they opened one of these closets and
found it filled with weapons decorated
with varieties of gold and silver and
jewels
and then they went to the fourth chamber
where also they found closets one of
which they opened and they found it full
of utensils for food and drink
consisting of various vessels of gold
and silver and saucers of crystal and
cups set with brilliant pearls and cups
of carnelian and other things
so they began to take what suited them
of these things that each of the
soldiers carried off what he could
and when they determined to go forth
from these chambers they saw their adore
of saaj inlaid with ivory and ebony and
adorned with plates of brilliant gold in
the midst of that palace
over it was hung a curtain of silk
worked with various kinds of embroidery
and upon it were locks of white silver
to be opened by artifice without a key
the shaykh of the samad therefore
advanced to those locks and he opened
them by his knowledge and boldness and
excellent skill and the party entered a
passage paved with marble upon the sides
of bridge where curtains were on were
figures of various wild beasts and birds
all these being worked with red gold and
white silver their eyes were of pearls
and just since
whosoever beheld them was confounded
next they came to a saloon
on beholding which the amir musa and the
samad were amazed at its construction
they then passed on and found a saloon
constructed of polished marble adorned
with jewels
the beholder imagined that upon its
floor was running water and if anyone
walked upon it he would slip
the amir musa therefore ordered the
shaykh
to throw upon it something that they
might be able to walk on it and he did
this and contrived so that they passed
on
and they found in it a great dome
constructed of stones gilded with red
gold the party had not be held in all
that they had seen anything more
beautiful than it and in the midst of
that dorm was a great dome crown
structure of alabaster around which were
lattice windows decorated and adorned
with oblong emeralds such as none of the
kings could procure
in it was a pavilion of brocade raised
upon columns of red gold and within this
were birds the feet of which were of
emeralds beneath each bird was a net of
brilliant pearls spread over a fountain
by the brink of the fountain was placed
a couch adorned with pearls and jewels
and descents whereupon it was a damsel
resembling the shining sun
eyes had not beheld one more beautiful
upon her was a garment of brilliant
pearls on her head was a crown of red
gold with a fillet of jewels on her neck
was a necklace of jewels in the middle
of which were refugent gems and upon her
forehead with two jewels the light of
which was like that of the sun and she
seemed as though she were looking at the
people and observing them to the right
and left
when the emir musa beheld this damsel he
wandered extremely at her loveliness and
was confounded by her beauty and the
redness of her cheeks and the blackness
of her hair
any beholder would imagine that she was
alive and not dead
and they said to her peace be upon thee
odamso but talib the son of sahel said
to the amir may god amend thy state know
that this damn soul is dead there is no
life in her
how then can she return the salutation
and he added oh amir she is skillfully
embalmed and her eyes have been taken
out after her death and quicksilver has
been put beneath them after which they
have been restored to their places so
they gleam and whenever the air puts
them in motion we behold the imagines
that she twinkles her eyes though she is
dead
upon this emir moses said extol be the
perfection of god who has subdued his
servants by death and after the couch
upon which was the damn soul it had
steps and upon the steps were two slaves
one of them whites and the other black
and in the hand of one of them was a
weapon of steel and in the hand of the
other a jeweled sword that blinded the
eyes and before the two slaves was a
tablet of gold
whereupon was read an inscription which
was this quote
in the name of god the compassionate the
merciful praise be to god the creator of
man and he is the lord of lords and the
cause of causes in the name of god the
everlasting the eternal in the name of
god the ordainer of faith and destiny o
son of adam how ignorant are you in the
long indulgence of hope and how
unmindful are you of your arrival of the
predestined period
knowest thou not that death has called
for thee and has advanced to seize your
soul
be ready then for departure and make
provision in the world for you will quit
it soon
where is adam the father of mankind
where are noah and his offspring where
are these sovereign kiras and caesars
where are the kings of india and al iraq
where are the kings of the regions of
the earth where are the amalekites where
are the mighty monarchs the mansions are
void of their presence and they have
quitted their families and homes where
are the kings of the foreigners and the
arabs they have all died and become
rotten bones
who are the lords of high decree they
have all died
where are the karoon and haman where is
shaddad the son of ad where are the
canaan and the lord of the stakes god
has cut them off and it is he who cuts
short the lives of mankind and he has
made the mansions to be void of their
presence
did they prepare provision for the day
of resurrection and make themselves
ready to reply to the lord of men
o you if you know me not i will acquaint
you with my name and my descent i am ted
moore the daughter of the king of the
amalekites of those who ruled the
countries with equity
i possessed what none of the kings
possessed and ruled with justice and
acted impartially towards my subjects
i gave and bestowed and i lived a long
time in the enjoyment of happiness and
an easy life and possessing emancipated
female and male slaves
thus i did until the summoner of death
came to my abode and disasters occurred
before me
and the case was this
seven years in succession came upon us
during which no water descended on us
from heaven
nor did any grass grow for us on the
face of the earth
so we ate what food we had in our
dwellings and after that we fell upon
the beasts and ate them and they
remained nothing
upon this therefore i caused the wealth
to be brought and melted it with a
measure and sent it by trusty men who
went about with it through all the
districts not leaving unvisited a single
large city to seek for some food
but they found it not and they returned
to us with the wealth after a long
absence
so thereupon we exposed to view our
riches and our treasures locked the
gates of the fortresses of our city and
submitted ourselves to the decree of our
lord committing our case to our master
and thus we all died as you behold and
left what we had built and what we had
treasured this is the story and after
the substance there remains nothing
but the vestige
and upon the tablet was also inscribed
these words caught whoso arrives at our
city and enters it god facilitating his
entrance if touch anything that is on my
body for it is the covering of my person
and therefore let him fear god and not
seize ought for it for he would destroy
unto him and a charge which i gave him
in confidence and peace be upon your
trials and sickness
the emir musa when he heard these words
again wept so violently that he became
insensible and after he had recovered he
wrote all that he saw and was admonished
by what he witnessed
he then said to his companions bring the
sacks and fill them with part of the
riches and the vessels and the rarities
and jewels
and thereupon talib the son of sahel
said to the emir musa o amid shall we
leave this damsel with the things that
are upon her they are things that have
no equal nor is the like of them any
time found and they are more than the
richest you had taken and will be the
best present by which you may ingrate
yourself with the prince of the faithful
but the me replied oh you did not hear
what the damsel had given us a charge in
the description upon this tablet
moreover and especially she has given at
the charged offered in confidence and we
are not of the people of treachery there
was iritalib however said and on account
of these words will you leave the riches
and these jewels when she is dead
what then should she do with these
things which are the ornaments of the
world and the decoration of the living
with a garment of cotton might the
damsel be covered and we are more worthy
of these things than she
then he drew near to the steps and
ascended them until he reached the spot
between the two men the slaves before
mentioned when lo one of these two smote
him upon his back and the other smart
him with the sword that was in his hand
and struck off his head and he fell down
dead
so the emir musa said may god not regard
with mercy your resting place
there was in these riches a sufficiency
and covetousness does doubtlessly
dishonor the person in whom it exists
he thereupon gave orders for the entry
of the troops who accordingly entered
and they loaded the camels with part of
the riches and minerals after which the
emir mozart commanded them to close the
gates as it was before
they then proceeded along the seacoast
until they came in sight of a high
mountain overlooking the sea
in it were many caves and low in these
was a people of the blacks cladden hides
and with burness of hides upon their
heads whose language was not known
and when they saw the troops they ran
from them and fled to those caves while
their women and their children stood at
the entrances of the caves
so the imirmusa said o sheikh abdul
samad what are these people and he
answered these are the objects of the
inquiry of the prince of the faithful
they therefore allied it and the tents
were pitched and the riches were put
down
and they had not rested when the king of
the blacks came down from the mountain
and drew near to the troops
he was acquainted with the arabic
language therefore when he came to the
emir musa he saluted him and the emir
returned his salutation and treated him
with honor
then the king of the black said to the
emir
are you of mankind or the jinn
the emit answered as to us we are of
mankind
and as to you there is no doubt that you
are of the jinn
because of your seclusion in this
mountain that is separated from the
world and because of the greatness of
your make
but the king of the blacks replied nay
we are a people of the race of adam of
the sons of ham the sons of noah on whom
be peace
and as to the sea it is known by the
name of al-qarkar
sudamir musa said to him how did you
obtain this knowledge when there has not
come unto you any prophet divinely
inspired in such a country as this
he answered no oh amir that there
appeared to us from the sea a person
defusing a light whereby the surrounding
tracts are illuminated and he proclaimed
with a voice which the distant and the
near hear o sons of ham be abashed at
him who sees and is not seen and say
there is no god but god muhammad is the
apostle of god and i am abu labas
al-hazir
before that we used to worship one
another but he called us to worship the
lord of mankind
then he said to the emir musa
he has also taught us some words to say
and what asthma are these words he
answered they are these
there is no god but god alone he has no
partner to him belongs dominion and to
him belongs praise he gives life and
kills and he is able to accomplish
everything and we seek not access to god
to whom we ascribe might and glory saved
by these words nor know we any others
also every night of friday we see a
light upon the face of the earth and we
hear a voice saying perfect holy lord of
the angels and the spirit whatsoever god
wills comes to pass and what he wills
not comes not to pass every benefit from
god is a favor and there is no strength
nor power but in god the high the great
the emir musa then said to him we are
the associates of the khalifa of islam
abdul malik
and we have come on account of the
bottles of brass that are here in your
sea and wherein are the devils
imprisoned from the time of solomon the
son of david on both of whom be peace
he has commanded us to bring him some of
them that he may see them and divert
himself by the view of them and the king
of the blacks replied most willingly
then he feasted him with fish and
ordered the divers to bring up from the
sea some of the bottles of solomon and
they brought up for them twelve bottles
where with the emir musa was delighted
and the sheikh abdul samad also and the
soldier on account of the accomplishment
of the affair of the prince of the
faithful the emir musa thereupon
presented to the king of the black's
many presents and gave him large gifts
in like manner too the king of the
blacks gave to the emir musa a present
consisting of wonders of the sea in the
form of human beings and said to him
your entertainment for these three days
shall be of these fish
and the amy replied we must care with us
some of them that the prince of the
faithful may see them for thereby will
his heart be pleased more than by the
bottles of solomon
then they made him farewell and they
journeyed back until they came to the
land of syria and went into the prince
of the faithful whereupon the emir musa
acquainted him with all that he had seen
and all that had occurred to him with
respect to the verses and histories and
admonitions and told of him the case of
talib the son of sahel
and the prince of the faithful said to
him word that i had been with you that i
might have beheld what ye beheld
he then took the bottles and proceeded
to open one after another and the devils
came forth from them saying repentance
or prophet of god we will not return to
the like conduct ever
and abdul malik ibn marwan wandered at
this
after this the prince of the faithful
caused the riches to be brought before
him and divided them among the muslims
and he said god has not bestowed upon
anyone like what he bestowed upon
solomon the son of david
then the emir musa begged the prince of
the faithful that he might appoint his
son in his place as governor of the
province and that he might himself go to
the noble jerusalem where to worship god
so the prince of the faithful appointed
his son to the government and he himself
went to the noble jerusalem and he died
there
this is the end of which has come down
to us of the history of the city of
brass
and god is all-knowing
and that is thus the end of the city of
brass quite a long story i hope
some of you stuck around for the entire
thing
one of the spookier episodes from the
thousand and one nights although also
very much a kind of classic
thousand and one nights tale in many
ways it has a lot of the themes
that most of those stories have
there is a clear morale to this story
it's a spooky story right so they come
to the city they find completely
disturbed everyone's
dead especially the scene with the
the sort of the princess or the damn
soul as they describe her on the steps
or in the couch in this
inner chamber or this great palace
the scene where
she has been embalmed and her eyes have
been
replaced it's a very sort of gruesome
scene
and i also really like the the part
where they find this
gin that's stuck in this the pillar and
him then telling his story there's a lot
of really
great stuff in in the story it's quite a
dark story to be honest now
what's the most recurring theme of this
story the sort of morale of the story as
i'm sure most of you have noticed is
that they see these great treasures they
come to this city that is just
beyond
anything that they have ever experienced
the great
treasures great riches the great kings
and
queens have lived here they have been a
rich society and now everyone's dead and
in all these inscriptions on the wall is
basically the same message which is
to boil it down which is the basic
message of the story as i interpret it
is that it doesn't matter how much
wealth you
accumulate how much power you have in
the world because everyone will one day
die right and you cannot take any of
those witches with you to the grave
when you are in the ground
you are equal to everyone else and all
your riches and all your powers and all
your palaces and great cities
don't really matter at all
and so these
inscriptions on the walls of these
palaces are kind of like cries
from these people who realized this fact
when it was already too late they hadn't
prepared properly
from the perspective of the morality
story right they hadn't prepared
properly for death but instead it
focused too much on worldly desires and
worldly pleasures
of course a very classically
religious
morale kind of story but i think one
that is very striking and in some ways i
think it's very accurate right you don't
need to be religious or follow a
specific religion to know that
you know greed is never the answer
because at the end of the day we're all
going to die everyone will meet their
grave and meet their death at some point
and so to
focus or to to have your life be focused
entirely on worldly pursuits at the end
of the day isn't really going to
mean anything
once that life ends and that is
how i interpret the
essential message of this story to be
but what i really really like about the
story of course is the the spooky nature
of it right this
abandoned city these
dead bodies and all the gins and and
it's a very classic sort of arabian
nights atmosphere that is described here
and i think it's just lovely in so many
different ways
and that is going to do it for this
year's shocktober
it's been a really fun month i love
doing these episodes where i talk about
these more sort of spooky or darker or
more
mysterious aspects of religion and
history it's it's the kind of stuff that
i really love doing and so it's going to
be a recurring theme but this is going
to be the last episode there might be
an episode coming out soon which is
going to actually be a review of a
recent uh tv show that came out which
has some religious themes that i want to
discuss but other than that this will be
the end of the month of shocktober as we
call it here for all of you out there i
hope you have a wonderful
evening a wonderful day depending on
when you're watching this if you're
celebrating halloween i wish you a happy
halloween if you celebrate sauhan i wish
you a happy and
meaningful song and if it's just a
sunday then i hope you have the best
sunday
of your entire life and i wish you all
the best
i will see you
in the next video
thank you
[Applause]
story
you